they had them off
in um committee session yeah that's
so like my heaviest was during the
pandemic and I was like
device German power
book is here representative here
here
representative Kelly
representative Elwood
representative Brown here representative
Cahill
here representative Davis here it's
representative Tetro
here represent Trail 11.
representative Gilman here Mrs majority
here
representative
here representative Gallagher
here
representative Hicks here
representative Howland here and
representative priest here
and the chairman I am present uh just so
you know in place of
representative Guthrie today we have
representative Janine otter
very good
all right
let's get going on uh first executive
session uh house bill today will be
number 83.
relative to County
Commissioners Authority on County
buildings
Mr chairman
uh representative lasalles yes Mr
chairman I'd like to propose
an amendment to HB 83
2023.0119 h
and I'd uh move that the amendment be
passed do we have a second
like the Second That Emotion
thank you representative Brown uh
representative osalis would you like to
speak to your Amendment or demon yes the
amendment uh
uh just clarifies the bill a little bit
and uh basically it increases the
threshold
uh for County government to dispose of
property
uh including real estate it increases
that threshold from five thousand to
thank you representative is there a
seeing none will ask the clerk to call
the adopting Amendment 2023-0119h
[Music]
Vice chairman power yes
representative
yes
click votes yes representative yes
representative Elwood
yes
representative Brown yes
yes representative Cahill yes
representative Davis yes
representative Tetro
yes
representative Gilman yes
represent majority
yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
uh motion patches passes uh chairman uh
chairman I'm sorry I'll vote yeah you
thank you sir sorry about that
yes Mr chairman I propose that we uh
pass HB 83
OTP as amended thank you for the Motions
your second
I'd like to second that Mr chairman so
noted any discussion
seeing nonetheless the clerk to call the
world
representative nada
yes click votes yes representative
lasalles yes
representative Keller no
representative Kelly yeah
representative Elwood yes
representative Brown
yes
representative Cahill
representative stavis yes
representative Petro
yes
representative representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative howling yes
representative priest yes and the
chairman yes
okay on that uh Bill representative
lasalles will be writing the committee
report since it was unanimous is there
any objection to it going on to the
consent calendar
correction it was technically not
unanimous but I don't oppose you're
right 18-1 is there any
you're you're not opposed okay so it
will go on the consent calendar sorry
all right with that we'll close the
executive session on 83 and we'll open
up the executive session on House Bill
87.
and do we have a motion
I'd like to make a motion for House Bill
87 relative to the county responsibility
for capital building projects
I'm going to make I believe there might
be an amendment you'd like to make a
motion on first yes I'd like to make a
motion on uh House Bill 87 which amends
the uh responsibility clarifies the
County Convention to raise the capital
Improvement threshold to 25
2023-0118h do we have a second
I'll second that thank you would you
like to speak to that representative
Brown
this simply raises the capital threshold
from 5 000 to 25 000 and clarifies the
powers that are invested in the
convention
foreign
thank you representative any discussions
on the amendment
seeing none unless clerk to call the
rule
here dropped Amendment 118 h
uh representative power yes
representative naughter yes collect
representative Keller
no
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes
representative Cahill
yes Representatives Davis yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority
yes
representative megapody
yes representative Gallagher
yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes
and the chairman yes
motion passes 18 to one
I'd like to uh pass the Bill 87 as
Amendment amended
do we have a second
Mr chairman
thank you for the discussion
seeing none
less the clerk to call the role on HB 87
as amended
Vice chairman of power yes
uh representative yes click votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative Keller
no
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill yes
representative yes
representative Tetro yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher
yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Highland yes representative priest yes
and the chairman yes motion pass is 18
thank you Mr Clerk and
representative Brown you'll be writing
the committee report on that I
understand yes and since it was nearly
unanimous is there any objection to
going on the consent calendar
foreign
procedural question if there is just
even one The Minority Report is not
necessary right it's unanimous consent
okay uh close the hearing on uh house
bill or the executive session on HB 87
okay now we'll open up the exact session
and do I have a motion
representative power thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to make a motion on
House Bill 95 in expedient to legislate
thank you do I have a second I would
like to second that motion thank you
representative Cahill representative
power would you like to speak thank you
Mr chairman House Bill 95 enables
municipalities to adopt bylaws to be
able to regulate the notice required
prior to any rent increases on
Residential Properties and also to
regulate the allowable rental increases
um
we heard in testimony on this bill
um from several people that such a bill
if it were signed into a law would be
akin to rent control and we have seen in
other municipalities across the country
that rent control is a failed concept
for example we heard in testimony that
in 1994 Massachusetts repealed their
rent control additionally presently
municipalities do have the ability to
work with developers to build the
housing that's needed in their
municipalities
and last year we had a bill
2022 Senate Bill 400 that that um
makes Provisions
um
in that legis that bill that became law
to address the housing needs in our
state
additionally we're heard during the
hearing that Senate Bill 47 established
a commission to review affordability and
the inventory of housing in our state
it may be prudent to wait to get to to
see the results of that Commission
um we also heard in in during the
hearing that this bill would would in
fact hurt landlords who provide housing
for people in our state
um by essentially regulating their
incomes and their ability to
um be landlords and to be able to
provide housing stock and lastly I I
might add that it was also we heard
in the hearing in testimony that it's a
supply and demand issue and that perhaps
a better place to look would be at the
zoning side of this issue
so for those reasons
um I will be voting in expedient to
legislate thank you representative any
further discussion representative
Gallagher
um so
I as a co-sponsor of this legislation
I support this legislation it's enabling
legislation which
means that municipalities can choose
whether they want to adopt it or not so
if it doesn't make sense for communities
then let me probably won't adopt it and
there will be no harm done but
if it does make sense then they can
adopt in there are many places where it
is in fact
uh needed as for the case of
Massachusetts being brought up
um yes they did repeal their rent
control and
um
but
they're actually
considering bringing it back now and
that debate is still ongoing because so
far repealing their rent control has
led to rents going up too much and now
they need it back
um
S4
the part about landlords I I think it's
a mistake to consider them
housing providers I think a more
accurate term would be housing deniers
because the landlords
landlords hoard housing and then deny it
to anyone who can't pay the rent to them
so
we need
instead of
instead of putting landlords concerns
first we should be putting tenants
concerns first
and tenants
need to have rent that's payable
landlords should not be making money off
of
other people's basic need for housing
that's just immoral
um so
it's for those reasons that
I support
thank you representative Gallagher
representative priests
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm also
um in favor of this spill and I come
from District 17 or Ward 2 in the city
of Manchester where half of the housing
in my district is Apartments
and I saw firsthand in the last three
years
of massive evictions by predatory
landlords in my area
and as you know in that in this housing
market there isn't
apartment buildings available for these
people
and I know one case when I when I was
out um
with the election campaign and Jordan
knocking I met a man who lived in these
apartments for 17 years he was a veteran
he was 77 years old and they basically
increased his rent by a hundred and
fifty percent
he was not able to do that and he was
evicted from this home that he had his
established
for 17 years
I agree with Mr Gallagher I think this
is we're talking about a segment of our
population of our Workforce that cannot
afford to buy housing they have to rent
housing and we need a mechanism
four communities
to address this issue and because it's
not being addressed they have no place
to go right now to address their
concerns and their problems
and again this legislation is not
setting rental prices it's not dictating
landlords what to do
it's basically enabling communities like
the city of Manchester if they choose to
do so to enact a rental board to address
these issues
um
thank you
thank you representative representative
Russ Davis
thank you Mr chair
um I do not support this bill
but the reasons for my not supporting it
are
are different from what the vice chair
articulated I think that this is a
conversation that we as a state and as a
society badly need to have I am the
senior member on the planning board in
Lebanon New Hampshire which is a city of
approximately fifteen thousand people we
have
on average five or six developers coming
before our planning board at every
meeting
proposing Apartments
450 units 500 units 200 units and they
all want to take advantage of the the
state law that allows them a tax
exemption or a tax stabilization for
providing a certain percentage of
affordable units but that state that tax
stabilization goes away and after it
goes away those rents shoot up and they
shoot up far beyond market value and the
people who could previously have
afforded to live in them are evicted I
have a friend who's 82 years old she
lives by herself she has lived in a
one-bedroom apartment for 13 years her
rent was just increased by 60 percent
and she now has to go out in the dead of
winter by herself looking for another
place to live in Lebanon which is well
my impossible so I do not support this
bill because I believe it is to blunt an
instrument and I believe that this
conversation needs to be carried forward
perhaps in a in a series of of meetings
between our committee and the special
committee on housing I don't want to let
this issue go but I do not support this
bill in its current form thank you
thank you representative
yeah representative
thank you Mr chair
I am in support of the bill partly
because of the need for housing and it's
a crisis and one of the uh testifying
person was from legal assistance for
housing attorney I come from Nashua
which has
um you know it's a city of 90 000 people
and
a lucky I mean homelessness or houseless
individuals we are trying to provide
shelter temporary sheltered transitional
homes and stuff how do we transition
them out of that place so I understand
this is not an answer to all the
um
salute it's not the only solution for
the problem we face in the state and in
cities and communities of homeless
houseless individuals in it it's not a
crime being houseless or being poor is
not a crime so we can't treat it that
way so at least this creates the
conversation so at least we can address
it I totally agree with my colleague
representative stavis about save us
about uh
continuing the dialogue work from all
angles and with that spirit I will be
for the discussion representative
Gallagher
um so just to follow up on what
representative mangaputi said um yeah I
agree with her that being unhoused is
not a crime on the part of the person
who is unhoused I would argue though
that it's a crime on the part of society
for failing to house them and if not a
legal crime at least it's a moral
the moral of equivalent of a crime and I
I agree with her that we shouldn't be
criminalized criminalizing homelessness
but instead be criminalizing the people
who refuse to provide housing for those
representative Holland
so um I understand uh the the concern
particularly right now in my district uh
the vacancy rate in apartments is less
than half a percent and in a healthy
Market it's about five percent and so
the need to build more units is really
Paramount and I while I understand the
concern and it was really compelling as
we've heard about people whose rent has
increased I don't think you can control
the rent if you have such a slow Supply
if we had reached the five percent
healthy Market I could understand and
and there still was these excessive rent
increases occurring I can understand the
need then for municipalities to step in
and begin to regulate it but under
current conditions I think that this
will be counter to us developing the
housing stock that we need to get to
that point so as a result I'm going to
vote in Expedia to legislate
thank you representative uh
representative Hicks
uh thank you Mr chair I um agree with my
colleagues Representatives Davis and
representative Howland that this is not
the ants answer and actually has a
potential to prevent uh future Supply
which will exacerbate the problem of
representative Gallagher
so in response to the issue of Supply I
do agree that Supply is an issue
but we have other bills that will help
increase Supply and I think we should
pass those as well and if we pass those
as well then any Supply concerns about
this bill will be negated
which will just leave the positive
effects of giving security to
renters
who need protection
any further discussion seeing none
okay the motion is itl on HB 95.
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative
nodder yes
click Force yes representative lasalles
yes
representative yokawa yes
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes representative Cahill yes
Representatives Davis yes
the representative Tetro yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
Representative no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks yes
representative howling yes
representative Priest No
and the chairman yes
motion passes 16 to 3.
thank you Mr chairman
um
we have three no's uh
objection to going on to the consent
calendar yes thank you
um will there be a committee report I
assume yes and I will write it that'll
and uh from the Republican side uh I
will be writing the committee report on
say again
okay uh representative save us thank you
Mr chair could could you just repeat
um the the timetable the deadline for
the reports for today's session I was
thank you for reminding me I was going
to say that right after this bill uh
we'll close the executive session on
this bill uh
the clerk has asked uh due to a lack of
number of bills for our first house
session next Thursday is if anything
that we can get out of here today on to
the calendar for next week he would be
much appreciated so what I'm going to
ask we should be done fairly early I'm
going to ask everybody who is writing a
committee report today to remain here
and give me that report before you leave
that way we can get it onto the calendar
and it can be part of uh next Thursday's
house session
any questions on that
okay with that we will go ahead and open
up executive session on House Bill 422
FN
and Mr chair I have a motion
uh representative Gilman you have a
motion representative priest could you
turn off your mic please
I about to uh itl this bill do we have a
second second representative manager
putty seconds the motion and would you
like to speak to your motion
representative Gilman yes uh this bill
while well-intentioned leaves a lot to
leaves a lot of questions one for the
registry there is no mechanism no
infrastructure to start this new kind of
registry
uh two we don't know what kind of units
or how though there's no breakdown of uh
whether it's seasonal rinsing uh
short-term renting uh uh how many units
uh
Let's see we don't know what happens
with a unit that has Services provided
such as heat and hot water or
electricity
there's no way to enforce it
and uh and there's no there's no
breakdown no columns for the different
information that we need I feel that
this is not ready in the registry of
deeds was against it because they don't
have the infrastructure to complete it
thank you representative Is there
further discussion on this bill
representative Park
thank you Mr chairman I might also add
that um this bill is an unfunded mandate
and therefore is repugnant to the New
Hampshire Constitution pot first article
28a
thank you representative any further
discussion
itl hb422 Vice chairman power yes
representative NADA yes clerk votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative yokawa yes
representative Kelly
yeah uh representative Elwood
yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill
yes Representatives Davis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
Gilman
yes representative majority yes
representative yes representative
Gallagher no
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes
and the chairman yes
motion passes 18 to 1.
thank you Mr Clark is there any
opposition to this bill going on to the
seeing none
you close the exact session on House
Bill 422
three four
yes uh report
minority uh the uh
will representative Gilman you'll be
okay that closes the exact session on
House Bill 422 now we're going to open
and do I have a motion
and do we have a second a second
representative Elward seconds that
motion representative yokella would you
yes
um since the uh date change is
unworkable by the dra I think that
um there this bill is not ready for
prime time at this at this time thank
you thank you representative any further
discussion
itl on HB 98
Vice chairman of power yes
representative yes
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes
representative Cahill yes representative
Davis
yes
uh representative yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority yes
representative
yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Highland yes
representative preach yes and the
chairman yes
motion passes 19-0
thank you Mr clerk opposition to the
consent calendar seeing none it'll go on
the consent calendar thank you we close
the access session on hb98 and open
house bill exact session on House Bill
295 do I have a motion representative
status
thank you Mr chair I would like to move
to retain house bill 295.
do we have a second
representative second and I'd like to
speak to my motion representative go
ahead
um I I think that the intent of this
bill is positive
and it would be a good thing a very good
thing and would Advance the cause of
transparency in government across our
state for all town councils and other
and school boards and other public
bodies to have
live streaming or Video available for
their meeting processes and I see that
we we also have an amendment that just
came in today
which um which adds in addition to
school boards and budget committees
um public body meetings and hearings
which is which is a vast Improvement on
the original bill because it include it
it's a catchment for all public bodies
so increases transparency
I do have some concerns though about
what my colleague representative power
described as an unfunded mandates
we heard testimony from people in towns
that do not have the kind of broadband
access that this legislation would
require them to install to purchase and
install and maintain an update uh and
and so I'm concerned about those towns
and I'm concerned about in effect
levying a burden a cost burden on them
they may not be able to sustain
but I think because the intent of the
bill is a positive intent could yield
very beneficial results for New
Hampshire citizens I would like to
retain the bill work on it further with
the sponsor and with others and and make
it ready for passage thank you thank you
representative for the discussion
representative power
thank you Mr chairman um I would like to
Echo some of the points that my
colleague just made and to re reiterate
the point that as the bill is is written
as written it does violate the New
Hampshire Constitution part one article
28a as an unfunded mandate
um
yes many towns do not have Broadband
capabilities of at this time and such a
bill if it were to become law would
require equipment purchases to be made
by municipalities
so um The Spill is is is not ready at
thank you representative representative
Manchester thank you Mr chair I do
um I do agree with both of my colleagues
who made the comment about it it is a
good intention it will open up the
public I mean democracy or the public uh
debate and participation but it's one
way in terms of it's a passive observing
and there's no way uh in a town
town meeting where the voters come and
vote there's no way of voting back
electronically they can participate by
watching it or public testimony but not
because that's not available uh in our
uh like with the Odyssey 91 which would
allow for electronic or virtual
participation that's not in existence
right now so this is a good bill needs
work and I would fully support the
retaining of it and work on it to
increase the participation
further discussion representative ukella
thank you um I kind of wish that this
motion was made after a discussing of
the amendment to understand why
um the amendment doesn't doesn't reach
the concerns of of the people since it
hasn't been uh
proposed then we can't really discuss
the merits and demerits of the uh
Amendment and I think
um
that is kind of I think that this motion
is kind of premature so thank you
further discussion representative Hicks
so seeing that thank you Mr chair um
if we are to retain this I think that
the point of increasing the visibility
of our public meetings is is Paramount
um
we need more people to see our meetings
we need full transparency in government
and so whatever we can do including
um
researching how to fund this to help our
smallest towns I would be in support of
that because I think that is only going
to serve the people of New Hampshire
by allowing them to participate
thank you thank you representative
uh representative Gallagher
um so
about the um
or
minor Point slash question about process
so
if we retain it we'll still be able to
pick up the amendment again after
is that correct
yes okay so yeah um
so I I do think the amendment deserves
consideration but um I I don't really
see why that's an argument against
retaining it though since we can still
discuss the amendment
um after the bill comes back from
retaining
seeing none well I will call the world
please
and state the motion HP 295 the motion
is to retain the bill
Vice chairman power no
Representative no
click votes no Representative lasalles
no
Representative yokella no
representative Kelly
representative Elwood no representative
Brown no
representative Cahill no
Representatives Davis yes
uh representative Tetro yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative
yes
representative Gallagher
uh yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes and the
chairman no
motion fails uh 10 to 9. nine to ten
uh thank you Mr clerk do we have a
further motion
thank you Mr chair I would like to make
a motion to itl on HB 295
thank you representative Cahill uh
second
Mr chairman I'd like to second that
okay representative power seconds the
motion
you'd like to speak yes
um could you just hit your mic there
representative
I'm making the motion to RTL because it
violates
article one
28a
thank you
for the discussion
representative yukela
thank you um I don't believe that
um that 91a is a violation of of uh 28a
and this is just an extension of 91a in
in making things public uh you know
I would say that actually we need to be
um you know open and transparent is
another part of the uh Constitution and
so in that sense
um it is required by the Constitution
that they
um be open and transparent and we are
just defining what open and transparent
means so therefore
um it is required
um that they pay to be open and
transparent and so it's not an unfunded
mandate it's required in the
Constitution that they be that way
so I disagree with that argument thank
I'm just going to make one quick comment
on this
um
while the overall intent on transparency
I think is very good the bill itself and
then a last minute
Amendment
um is not ready uh
I my my thought would be to come back
next next year with something that's a
little bit uh
a little bit more tight
um as a committee and just for future
references I'm not a huge fan of
operating on the Fly representative
yokella mentioned a last minute
um
Amendment on this
I I know occasionally we're going to see
that with a few minor word changes but
it's best when you have a major
amendment to try to get that to the
committee as soon as possible so for
those reason I do believe we should I
tell it I'm not opposed to more
transparency in government obviously
everybody wants that but this bill here
does not do it in the proper way thank
you
for the comments
yeah no
thank you Mr chair the only thing I
would add which is to add to what you
just said I agree with everything I down
in Northampton has has a very uh
vigorous and and robust uh system to
broadcast and I think that that should
be I would hope that that could be in
every town but even the amendment which
we just received says the bill takes
effect 60 days after passage had we
considered that it would have been
absolutely impossible for any Community
to be able to build these things in for
instance Northampton how to negotiate
that through our cable franchise
contract which took the better part of a
year so I agree the intent a hundred
percent it just needs a little work
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Gallagher
thank you Mr chairman
um
I wanted to say that online
um 14 where they're talking about
archives
oh what are we doing
yes we're not talking about an amendment
we're on the we've got a motion on the
Florida itl the bill itself
oh very sorry very sorry misunderstood
representative Gallagher
um so I think
regardless of whether the amendment was
made last minute or not or
um I do think we at least deserve to be
able to talk about it and have a
separate vote on it so I will be
opposing
um opposing the motion to itl
not because I think we should pass it
but I think we should just have a chance
to make a motion on the amendment first
thank you representative seeing no more
hands we'll ask the clerk to State the
motion and call the roll
HBO 295 and the motion is itl
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Nutter yes click votes
yes representative lasalles yes
representative yokawa
no
representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes
representative Cahill
yes
representative Tetro no
representative majority
no
Representative no
representative Gallagher
no
representative Hicks no
representative howling now
representative Priest No
and the chairman yes
thank you Mr Clark
um
I'm assuming this will then go on to the
regular calendar
um
majority report representative Cahill
you'll be writing yes Mr chair thank you
and representative stavis The Minority
and with that we will close the hearing
and we will now open up exec session on
hb416
and do I have a motion representative
Park
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to move
in Expedia into legislate on House Bill
416.
representative Elward
a sec
second thank you
Russian power would you like to speak to
your motion representative Elwood Mike
please
thank you Mr chairman this this bill
um pertained to
restrictions or prohibitions on the
membership on certain local land use
boards
unfortunately
um
the hearing was was very brief as there
was um no input on that bill it was just
um
introduced by I believe a Committee
Member here and so the text of the bill
was interesting and the committee was
unable to ask questions of the Prime
sponsor and additionally there were no
people present to provide testimony
therefore the committee was unable to
make an informed decision with regards
to this bill
so um
my motion is itl thank you
representative for the comments
HB 416 the motion is an Ito
Vice chairman of power yes
representative NADA yes click votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative yokella yes
representative Kelly
yeah representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill
yes Representatives Davis yes
representative Tetro yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Holland yes
representative priest yes and the
chairman yes
Ito passes 19-0
foreign
calendar unless there's an objection
which I see none that closes the exact
or one six
and representative power will be writing
the committee report on that one
we're going to open up the exec session
on House Bill 77
do I have a motion representative
Holland thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion that house bill 77 Al
conference relative to the compensation
of County delegates is inexpedient to
legislate thank you representative do I
have a second
I second representative three seconds
representative Holland would you like to
speak to your emotion uh thank you Mr
chair this bill also was not represented
by the prime sponsor and therefore again
we didn't have a chance to hear the
intent of the bill and there was no one
as well to speak to it so it really
hindered our ability to make an informed
consent additionally we felt that the uh
Inc 75 percent increase in each delegate
uh was ex
75 increase to be paid for each Delegate
for each day was excessive it would have
thank you representative for further
discussion
I see none uh as the clerk to call the
world
HP 77 itl
Vice chairman power yes
representative naughter yes
click votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative of your killer Yes
representative Kelly yeah representative
Elwood yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes representative
stavis yes
representative Tetro
yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority yes representative yes
representative Gallagher
yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes
representative priest yes yes and the
chairman
um yes Ito passes 19-0
thank you Mrs clerk again a unanimous uh
vote any opposition to the consent
calendar I see none it'll go on the
consent calendar and that closes the
exec session on
I'm assuming representative Holland will
be writing the committee report yes very
good
okay let's open up the exact session now
do eight I'm sorry
184. I don't know where I got that
184. uh do I have a motion
representative Brown yes Mr chairman I'd
like to make a motion to itl House Bill
184 relative to public notice
requirements for Zoning Board of
adjustment parents thank you do we have
a second the second representative L
word seconds the motion representative
Brown would you like to speak
uh yes Mr chairman uh the the issue
really is that a lot of people in the
state do not have access to the internet
and we feel that it's better to post it
both uh online and publish it continue
to publish it newspapers
thank you representative further
discussion representative Hicks will I
support the motion I do think that at
some point we are going to have to
modernize and understand that not
everybody else has newspapers uh and
there are public libraries available for
people to visit to go on to websites uh
probably more cheaply than it is to get
a subscription to the newspaper
thank you thank you representative Hicks
is that better okay thank you so much
Josh
um I think it's very important that um
we try to
protect you know our freedom of speech
and one of the ways we're doing it is to
protecting our local newspapers in this
state and by putting in these
um
requirements for public hearings is a
source of income for them
and I think we should do everything we
can to support them and to keep them
alive as long as possible and that's why
I am voting the way I am thank you thank
you representative further discussion
representative elwin
uh I don't believe this is about
newspapers and income
I believe this RSA regarding notice
is about due process
and it is also about standing
so the term a butter can mean for
purpose of certified mail
those properties of budding the subject
property
but then we have
a further definition of a butter
which means people who can prove that
there is a going to be an impact on
their property and it's presumptuous to
assume that
any
everyone lives within a local newspaper
distribution area
so I'm opposed to the bill
um I do believe that we need to
protect uh legal notice and do it right
and this bill is not it
thank you representative
thank you Mr chair
I hope to see this bill come back in
some iteration at some future date
because in the last session we in fact
did
bring up into the 20th maybe even the
21st century
some bills about public noticing of
meetings and elect using Electronic
media Etc in addition to newspapers
which are failing all over the state
and so I hope that at some point perhaps
this committee might be instrumental in
crafting a bill that unifies all of the
various public notice requirements in
the rsas pertaining to different public
bodies so there is less confusion so
that it doesn't become an unfunded
mandate
when the New Hampshire Constitution was
written I do not believe that every
town in New Hampshire had a daily
newspaper so
um times change circumstances change and
I do hope to see this build back again
sometime and we could do some really
good work on it thank you Mr chair thank
you representative I'm going to make a
comment quickly here maybe that'll
eliminate the need for prolonged
discussions I've spoken with the the
prime sponsor he understands that the
bill needs some refining and I believe
he will most likely bring a
another bill that is refined back next
year there's a further discussion on
this
representative Gilman
I had a question but I think you just
for the discussion representative Park
thank you Mr chairman um my concern with
regards to this bill is the in lieu of
publication and paper I would remind
everybody that in order to access
Internet be it under your own roof or in
a public place
one needs both electricity and internet
thank you representative further
comments seeing none I'll ask the clerk
HP 184 motions itl the vice chairman
power yes
representative Nutter yes clerk votes
yes representative Salas yes
representative Keller no
representative Kelly
representative Elwood
yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes representative
Davis yes
yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority yes representative yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes
and the chairman yes
motion passes 18 to 1.
without objection this will go on the
consent calendar seeing no objection it
will go on the consent calendar
and
representative Brown will be writing the
committee report on
oh no actually I'll be writing the
committee report on that one sorry about
that
okay that closes the exact session on
we'll open up the final bill house bill
197.
executive session
relative to the proration of property
tax exemptions
do we have a motion representative
majority thank you Mr chair I would like
to move ought to pass on this beautiful
okay do I have a second representative
Mr chair I've made an error Amendment
yes Mr chair thank you
and thank you Mr clerk uh Mr chair I
move ought to pass on the amendment for
House Bill 197 which I handed out to
everybody and didn't give a copy to
myself so I apologize for not having the
number
which is number
thank you do I have a second
representative priest seconds would you
like to speak to your Amendment thank
you Mr chair I would like to speak to
the amendment uh when the bill was
adopted a concern or when the bill was
proposed the concern came up that if the
bill would have passed each Community
would have to re-adopt all the
provisions under the RSA the amendment
um allows for uh the bill to pass
without having to re-adopt in every
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call a
role and representatives majority and uh
Rhys turn off your mics please
khp197 adopt the amendment zero zero
five seven eight
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Nutter yes click votes
yes representative lasalles yes
represent your color Yes representative
Kelly yes
yes representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill
yes
representative stavis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
Gilman yes representative majority yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howell yes representative
preach yes and the chairman yes
motion passes 19 to zero
do I have a further motion
yes Mr chair thank you I would like to
move
otpa
on House Bill 197.
thank you do I have a second
representative three seconds the motion
would you like to speak
thank you Mr chair I would like to speak
I appreciate that the intent of House
Bill 197 is to bring Equity it was bring
Equity to those who are
paying taxes in their communities this
was brought to me by the assessor in the
town of Hudson who I trust who I trust
all the time is testify for this
committee many many times in similar
fashion which his interest is to just
make sure that there is an equity that
there is equity he discovered that in
this instance
without this bill folks might be
receiving uh folks might be paying less
of their fair share this bill again
brings that into line and that is the
full intent of the bill
thank you representative any further
discussion
seeing none unless the clerk to call the
rule
Vice chairman sorry about that uh Vice
chairman of power yes
representative naughter yes
click folks yes representative Salas yes
representative yokella yes
representative Kelly yes representative
of Elwood yes representative Brown
yes representative Cahill
yes Representatives Davis yes
uh representative Tetro yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority yes
representative yes representative
Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Holland yes
representative preach yes and the
uh pastors 19-0
thank you Mr clerk if there's no
objections this will go on to the
consent calendar seeing no objections it
will do that I'm going to close the
exact session on HB 197 remind oh uh I'm
assuming representative majority will be
writing the committee report yes sir
very good I'm going to remind everybody
if you are writing a committee report
for something we did today you need to
have that to me shortly please as
quickly as possible we'd like to get
this on the uh calendar for next
Thursday so I see a smiling individual
in the back of the room so I'm sure
he'll be happy with that other than that
uh there any other questions comments
from the committee seeing none we'll see
you all here tomorrow morning at 10 A.M